The women of the MCU got their due in Avengers:
Endgame, and now one of the film's directors
has given a spoiler-filled explanation telling
us how and why it happened.
At the film's climax, the Avengers faced off
against a galactic army brought through a
time portal by the past version of Thanos.
In an attempt to prevent Thanos from getting
the rebuilt Infinity Gauntlet, the team worked
to transport the gauntlet across the battlefield
to the quantum realm portal in Scott Lang's
van.
And that's when a force comprised of nearly
every female hero in the Marvel Cinematic
Universe came together to help Captain Marvel
make the final push.
Asked by the Los Angeles Times why he considered
it to be important for the female heroes to
join forces for the scene, co-director Anthony
Russo said,
Avengers: Endgame screenwriters Christopher
Markus and Stephen McFeely also opened up
about the all-female scene.
McFeely told the New York Times
Markus added,
The scene certainly felt like a tip of the
hat to the MCU's female characters, on an
even bigger scale than the team-up between
Scarlet Witch, Black Widow, and Okoye against
Proxima Midnight in Avengers: Infinity War.
But the all-female moment within Avengers:
Endgame might have hinted at even more to
come.
In late 2017, Thor: Ragnarok actress Tessa
Thompson told Comic Book Resources that she
and several other Marvel stars had pitched
an all-female superhero team-up film to Marvel
head honcho Kevin Feige.
Feige was enthusiastic about the idea, telling
Vulture in early 2018 that it was, quote,
"all a matter of when and how."
Of course, that doesn't mean it will be any
time soon.
Fans have been clamoring for a Black Widow
film for years, but it won't arrive until
2020, a whole year after the character's tragic
sacrifice in Avengers: Endgame.
But there is precedent for an all-female team
of Avengers: in 2015, Marvel Comics unveiled
A-Force, a team led by She-Hulk which included
Captain Marvel, Nico Minoru of the Runaways,
and Jane Foster during her stint as Thor.
And the project may have gotten a boost from
the biggest star in the MCU, as Robert Downey
Jr. revealed recently on social media that
he had hosted a lunch for all of the MCU women
who could attend, with some of them even coming
in character!
Check out one of our newest videos right here!
Plus, even more Looper videos about the Marvel
Cinematic Universe are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit the
bell so you don't miss a single one.